le comité interprofessionnel des vins de
touraine agrandit son rayon d'action
il accueillera à partir du 1er septembre
prochain les appellations chinon
bourgueil saint nicolas de bourgueil
azay-le-rideau et crémant de loire un
volume commercialisables qui passera de
550000 à 750 mille hectolitres
mais le seuil vt lorgne aussi vers les
coteaux du loir le jasnières l'orléanais
et le valence et dans les départements
voisins
l'appellation fédérative val de loire
est ainsi pratiquement réalisé du
sancerre au muscadet sous l'égide de la
fédération interprofessionnelle des vins
du val de loire
il s'agit nullement d'une mise sous
surveillance de des appellations de
toute façon toutes les informations qui
sont traités ici sont le sont sous lé
sous le titre de la confidentialité et
nous sommes nullement à un organisme de
contrôle
il faut savoir que toutes les décisions
prises au niveau des interprofessions
sont prises par les professionnels eux
mêmes les professeurs des deux familles
qui constitue l'interprofession la
viticulture et négoce la signature des
accords interprofessionnels ne s'est pas
fait du jour au lendemain
du côté de saint nicolas de bourgueil il
y a eu des réticences
nous sentions que rester seul puisque
bourgueil chaînon avait adhéré
c'était très dangereux pour nous alors
nous avons pris la décision de prades et
de refaire ce vote qui avaient été
négatifs la première fois et de pouvoir
adhérer aux il était pour les raisons
importantes de la publicité surtout
parce que rester seul aujourd'hui avec
les budgets publicitaires que nous
pouvions dégagé s'était nettement
insuffisant désormais le comité
interprofessionnel des vins de touraine
et du coeur val de loire puisque ce sera
son nouveau nom rassemble deux mille six
cent viticulteurs et 150 négociants